12 of europe's biggest football club say
they'll launch a breakaway super league
six
english teams including liverpool
chelsea and
both manchester sides have agreed to
join
fellow european giants real madrid
barcelona and juventus will also play in
the league
the club's owners are being accused of a
power grab
football governing bodies fifa and uefa
are threatening
legal action
sports correspondent in italy he says
the proposed
european super league is all about money
it's a time where a footballer is not
only to bring people together or at
least that is the romantic side
but it is especially one of the biggest
industries in the world that is making
the most revenues
and possibly the biggest entertainment
factory with
cinema but the thing is that the
the people that are producing the
entertainment so the owners of the club
now wants much much more
revenues for them the pandemic obviously
have exposed them too much and possibly
they have lived over their possibilities
for
many years so they want much more money
and they want it now
and this project with these 12
funding clubs uh it is open though to
eight more uh this project
is guaranteeing them a huge slice since
the very beginning
what we are talking about here a slice
of 350 million
of euros just for subscribing to this
project